[Music]
hey Wolfgang we have one day left until
we get to see Avengers infinity warrior
we get to see all of our favorite
characters on screen again how long
they'll be on screen before they die I
don't know but we get to see them all
together again before we get started
with the video don't forget to enter our
giveaway for your chance to win a full
surround sound speaker system for your
home all you need to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous wave and like and comment
this video who your favorite superhero
is Marvel DC are otherwise full details
are in the link above since there's only
one day left I decided to do a video on
the Infinity Ward prelude comics that
came out it was a two-part book so today
we'll be talking about infinity war
Prelude part 1 the comic starts off with
a word-for-word reiteration of Captain
America Civil War the movie it starts
off where Baron Zemo is showing Tony
Stark Steve Rogers and Bucky the footage
of how Bucky killed Tony Stark's parents
in the past
after the video Tony enraged asks Steve
Rogers if he knew that Bucky murdered
his parents in which he replies yes Tony
then hits Captain America Way and starts
his attack on Bucky as he attacks him
Captain America jumps back in trying to
convince Tony that it wasn't him that
Hydra had control over his mind but Tony
doesn't care he just wants to kill the
guy that killed his parents Captain
America Iron Man and Bucky eventually
fall to the bottom of the building that
they've been fighting in and Captain
America and Iron Man get up and which
Captain America says this isn't gonna
change what happened and Iron Man
replies I don't care he killed me and
then they proceeded with one of the most
epic fights that we've seen in the MCU
at the end of it all Iron Man blasts off
Bucky's metal arm and Captain America
jumps on top of Iron Man and destroys
his arc reactor causing his suit to shut
down as Steve gets up and helps Bucky
and starts to walk away Tony yells at
him saying that the shield doesn't
belong to him that he doesn't deserve it
and his father made that shield and
which then Captain America drops his
shield and leaves here's where the comic
gets really interesting because it shows
things that
happened that we did not see in civil
war that lead up to Avengers infinity
war Captain America and Bucky limp
outside where they meet to chala
T'Challa then greets Captain America and
Bucky saying sorry to Bucky because he
believed him to be the man that killed
his father when in fact it was Baron
Zemo he then offers help to Bucky saying
that he can help erase his mental
programming that turns him into a Hydra
assassin he states that as soon as he
delivers emo to the United Nations he
will return to help Bucky in which
Captain America and Bucky replied that
they have a few loose ends to take care
of themselves and that they'll be in
touch
turns out captain and Bucky's unfinished
business is breaking into the raft
high-security prison to break out the
rest of Captain America's team here
Captain America breaks out Sam Wilson
aka Falcon Scott Lang aka ant-man Clint
Barton aka Hawkeye and Wanda Maximoff
aka The Scarlet Witch at this little
reunion Clint Barton announces that he
is officially retired it VIN shows a
clip with him being with his family
again saying you've got to enjoy the
time you got with the ones you love
while you have it perhaps maybe a little
bit of foreshadowing here of some tragic
event that might take place at infinity
war yeah it did shows ant-man going back
and being with his daughter but the most
interesting is that Wanda meets up with
vision but he's in human form we've seen
him in human form in the trailer as well
and I'm really curious to see what the
storyline is here we think cut to a
scene with Captain America and Bucky
with King T'Challa in Wakanda in Wakanda
King to chala states that an order for
Bucky to be rid of his mental
programming he'll have to return to cryo
sleep stasis
Bucky agrees saying that it's really the
only option he has and a few months
later she remakes a breakthrough here's
where it gets really interesting
cheeri states that she's developed an
algorithm that will be able to flush out
the influence of the trigger words while
retaining the court context and content
of those original memories that Bucky
has essentially rebooting him but that's
not the interesting part the interesting
part is that Shuri states that the
algorithm should provide even greater
advancement and will conda's own
artificial intelligent applications in
the near future she also states that
it's much simpler than the silly
shortcut Tony Stark took and creating
Ultron stating that of course it's
because she's smarter than him
this implies that she will have advanced
technology ready for when vision arrives
in Wakanda an infinity war this will
most likely mean that she will be able
to remove the mind stone from visions
for head without killing him I'm not
gonna speculate too much because again
just one more day to wait this next
scene shows a group of terrorists with a
Chitauri fueled weapon for those of you
who aren't familiar with the Chitauri
they're the alien army that invaded New
York and the first Avengers movie under
the command of Loki so basically it's an
alien bomb but surprise Captain America
the Falcon and Black Widow are among the
organization in disguise of course they
defeat them with ease and Captain
America states that the need to strip
the weapons of the Chitauri components
so no one else tries to modify them
Black Widow then asked Steve if he's
sure that he doesn't want to call Tony
Stark on this and what she replies I'm
sure he's got enough on his plate the
group from here then proceeds on to
Lebanon this is actually really cool to
see because this is actually the Secret
Avengers storyline from the comics and
the last page takes us back to the
Avengers compound where it shows Tony
Stark with the iron spider suit in the
back tony is beating himself up he's
feeling really guilty and he says that I
got distracted didn't focus on the real
threat that's coming he of course is
referring to the vision that he got in
Avengers age of Ultron and the vision he
saw all of the Avengers dead except for
himself and he also saw an alien army
attacking earth Tony knows that the
invasion is coming and he knows that he
needs to prepare for it obviously still
being very hurt after he fought Captain
America and Civil War he states that if
he made the call he's sure Steve would
answer but will that be enough
we then see a hologram of the brand-new
Iron Man bleeding-edge armor suit he
then says I'll have to figure out how I
can do it alone and that concludes the
infinity war prelude part 1 I hope you
enjoyed it and let me know what your
thoughts are and let me know if you have
any questions in the comments below and
again don't forget to enter a giveaway
by subscribing to my channel liking this
video and commenting below your favorite
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]